the jurogan experience didn't harvard
have epstein money did he yeah they well
in the science yeah well he definitely
donated some money to science yeah you
know but i had a conversation with a
scientist who didn't buy into that
ebstein stuff and wouldn't go to the
meetings and stuff like that and he said
he was really
shocked at how little money he actually
donated
interesting yeah he goes it wasn't that
much money he goes it was really like he
he was more than that he was bringing
them to parties
like it was a it was an intelligence
operation
whoever was running it whether it was
the mossad or whether it was a cia or
whether it was a combination of both it
was an intelligence operation they were
bringing in people and compromising them
and then when they would compromise them
they would use
you know whatever they had on them to
influence
their opinions and the way they express
those opinions
and i don't know why they would want to
do that with scientists which is really
strange to me epstein's like i need you
to do a study about how 15 year old
girls are adults they're more mature
than we thought
but if a scientist donates
i'm sorry if a rich person donates to a
scientist do they have any ability to
weigh in
or they're just like here's a i get no
decisions about how this money spent
it's a very good question
i don't know
i don't know i mean i would imagine the
money goes like if you have a research
grant right and say like you're working
on a cure for leukemia or something like
that
you know you find established scientists
that are working on this thing and then
you you allocate money so they can work
on projects whether or not the person
who donates the money has
any influence on how that money is spent
i doubt it i highly don't i don't think
legitimate scientists would
allow that yeah because i mean i know
that just my you know if you're shooting
an independent movie that has investors
russian investors saudi investors like
you have to hang out with them oh really
oh yeah
they're at video village like it's kind
of the it's like you have to flirt with
them here
here it says epstein regularly visited
had card key access to and was provided
a designated office space within the
program in evolutionary dynamics until
2018 so that means they they gave him
that at harvard after he had been
arrested for [ __ ] underage girls had
an office yeah granting him that level
of access raises serious questions about
the compliance with harvard's policies
and beginning in 2017 about whether or
not the professor no walk acted in
deliberate circumvention of harvard
security procedures
so he was arrested and did he'd already
did time by then which is crazy it's
also like at first i was like oh god he
was on campus with all these like girls
how scary but they were probably too old
for him so look at this here harvard
university said friday that convicted
sex offender jeffrey epstein donated
more than 9 million to the university
over the course of a decade and had an
office on campus after his 2006 arrest
nope so he was arrested in 2006 and then
after that up until 2018
still had an office there
that is why
old
but here's the thing
whatever he was doing and i don't know
why he was doing it you know and no one
knows now that he's dead
but he
had
a lot of scientists that he was tight
with
and that was one of the things that he
did was bring these scientists to that
island and he would have young girls on
that island
but like what's the end goal there this
is what i don't understand and what's
really crazy
is
galaine maxwell is in a minimum security
prison
she teaches you he's allowed to do yoga
she's allowed hang out watch tv watch
netflix
and is she allowed to use email to send
us the list that's what i was gonna say
the list
has not been released like there is a
[ __ ] list and this is not a mystery
there's not a mystery to the people that
yeah there's her hippo campus pull out
her hippocampus have a lawn put that
freaking thought reading
elon [ __ ] sorry no
you know what i've been friends with
elon gold for so long
well long gold probably can do an
impression of elon musk so there you go
uh elon gold does amazing impressions he
um used to call me and prank me as other
people all the time and one time he
called me as jeff goldblum and i was
like busy and i was like stop [ __ ]
bothering me dude and i kept hanging up
on him and then like an hour later it
was actually jeff goldblum he's like oh
this is actually me uh can you stop
hanging up on me
so random but but let me ask you
is it something as insane is this
because what's more profitable than you
know new cutting-edge science whether
it's a you know a prescription whether
it's a finding whether it's something
like does he if he donates to some kind
of scientific discovery that's going to
be lucrative down the line a pill a
medicine a cure does he get any kind of
power over it or money from it well some
of these scientists were string theory
physicists
like they're not inventing [ __ ] okay
like
some of the the stuff that they were
working on is like this very bizarre
kind you mean theoretical stuff
i don't know how that's applicable to
anything financial